hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village
i forgot in the last episode to consult
the therapeutic relaxing presence
of where is she where's
where is she where the frick is she oh
this [ __ ] gonna die they took
my [ __ ] crystal imatrescu
all right i'ma kill you
yeah i'm gonna kill you yeah i'm gonna
kill you you know what i'm gonna kill
you
you know what i've had about enough of
you
[Laughter]
i've had about enough of you you're dick
giggling you're chortling
man this place is a lot dirtier than i
remember there's a lot more dolls
[Music]
yeah okay this is normal oh don't leave
i can't let you okay you are still alive
do i do i really have to oh
god
all right i'ma kill you you got my
crystal dimitrescu
ah i would really like that back
i would really like that back
okay i'm gonna follow the kind of
obvious yellow clue
so uh
yeah anyway could i just have that back
i'll go home hey how you doing there you
are
i gotcha
ow what
okay cool uh peekaboo
all right i guess i'm guessing i go find
you again
well this is just delightful and um i'm
really having a good time but if you
could just give me back my dimetrescu
i can get back to the demotrescue
dimmidome and you know
just all good time you know i hear
someone chuckling
i didn't know i got that back
well rose is in several pieces so
there's not really much that i could do
to rose
so uh if anything i'd just be stitching
her back together
um hey what's up
how are you doing i'm never going to get
out of here
i think oh
stupid idiot what are you doing to my
cute
friends
oh oh
it's over
yeah i'll just reach in for that i'll
make things right
uh-huh yeah i will absolutely 100
hello rose
all right good uh cool
um yeah uh
yep okay
four-winged unborn king
all right this looks too great yep i got
two of rows and somehow this is all
gonna combine
and be fine oh hi
yeah all right well oh i can leave now
okay do i have
examine examine
now that that's comforting
this is what comfort feels like feels
like home
okay anyway so um uh okay i got
two of rose uh
the legs flask
oh good the leg yep that looks like
legs in there so who made
this because that's clearly umbrella
and that means that somehow umbrella's
all tied into this so i'm guessing that
mia made some
kind of deal with them to suggest
that there was no other way for her to
make a baby and in terms of
making the deal in return they would get
some of the biological information and
for some reason chris redfield is all a
part of this now and very chummy chum
chum about the
umbrella corporation which is
interesting
there's the drippies again oh blood
is that blood is that just brick the
writing isn't on the wall anymore so i'm
guessing that everything is cool
unless i'm going to be proven otherwise
which i'm ready for
surprisingly uneventful hello hi
can i get that photo back you remember
oh there's
nothing on the other side yeah okay that
makes sense
um oh there's a treasure here
some kind of a treasure here uh
you can't use that here oh was there
something else in
oh
there was probably something else in the
castle that like
[Music]
oh well too late now i'll get it later
but there definitely probably was
something else in there
that would have helped me complete
whatever that was and then i would have
been able to get that treasure
but i'm not going completionist here
i'm just going stupid can i have that
can i think about it thank you
all right so what is over here
hello hello
hello oh
oh ah money okay
cool well that was
okay hey but whoa wait whoa whoa
hey oh boy oh now we're back to zombies
now we're back to actually zombies i
still don't know how to push people
back
[Music]
it says space to push enemies away oh
ah so after you block you can push him
away
ah that makes sense
what was that how
much gsm
oh my god please tell me there's an
eventual time when i can upgrade my
knife
at this point i'd rather just shoot him
i would rather just shoot him
i don't know if there's only a limited
amount of bullets that i'm ever gonna
get in my life but at this point i would
rather just shoot him
it takes too long i'm a busy dude okay
here we go
you know what screw you guys i'm not
even gonna bother with you
wait is this always open
uh hello where the hell am i now
oh looks like there's a hole for
something spherical you got that right
buddy i don't know what this is
explosive
okay well that's cool that's really dark
in here wish i could see
november 10th mistress donna is now
mother miranda's adopted daughter in all
my years i've never been this overjoyed
ever since childhood she has always
feared others due to the scar across her
face
after her parents death she locked
herself away and would only talk to
angie
the doll her father made her i am
forever thankful to mother miranda's
infinite compassion
november 27th mistress donna seems happy
it might be my imagination but i feel
like her doll angie is even more lively
than before
she came to me in the garden a day and
used angie to talk with me
we had a mighty fine conversation
something about receiving a gift of
power from mother
november 29th mistress donna gave me
yellow flowers and told me to plant them
in the garden
i planted them in front of miss
claudia's grave i don't know if it was
the scent of the flowers but i felt
lightheaded
then like a dream i saw my departed wife
i mentioned this to donna and she seemed
thrilled by it she told me to go to the
house tomorrow and see her
she said i could see my family once more
i'm not sure what she meant by that
but she's so kind yeah
so kind i saw my family too that didn't
go as good as it seemed to go for you
but you know hey
to each their own you know all right so
i don't have any balls for that
i imagine the i imagine the bulls might
have something to do with they're
probably a
bull in there and then you do that but
i'll have to come back later for that
because i don't have what i need so i'm
going to go back i'm going to use the
key on the other place i'm going to talk
with the
big pop of duke and then i'm gonna
probably go back and try to get one of
the treasure pieces
or treasure things
well that's probably concerning i should
probably be concerned about that
but i'm not gonna be concerned about
that because i have crystal dimitrescu
in my pocket
hello oh
oh those used to be dolls i i really
remember distinctly those
yeah get flowered oh [ __ ] that was early
i'm a bit of a dumb ass
i might actually be a dumbass okay yeah
can i
oh you're really gonna act okay there we
go
okay later nerds
later douchebags kaboom
hey what's up nooky man what's up the
doe
okay how does this look familiar to you
yeah okay thanks uh yes
am i supposed to say yes am i supposed
am i supposed to say yes
yeah i'm gonna get rid of that i don't
want to keep that on me ah
miss angie just adorable
porcelain dolls are very popular you
know oh
yeah i know oh yeah i know
oh i so know
cool okay there we go my uh m1911
what is that oh for the showti gun oh my
goodness
that's great recoil was never really a
problem though so i'm not too worried
about that
i'm gonna get this just because i'm
gonna forward to test yeah i'm gonna
equip that now
and because eventually i'll do that but
i don't even think
i'm not 100 sure wait let me let me go
back and see a solid investment
so this does 140 damage this does 160
damage
that is a little better that is quite oh
and i could upgrade leave this to me eh
oh but this now does 100 okay well
what's even the point
what's even the point ah well all right
well you know well oh and now the uh
have a wonderful adventure i will thanks
buddy
okay i'm gonna go over here and i'm just
gonna open up this store and i'm gonna
go down to the other things and i'm
gonna go open that treasure thing and
i'm gonna
i'm gonna get it all i'm gonna do it all
i'm gonna get it all get out of my way
okay this is where i was before and i
wasn't able to actually get through here
i think i can now unlock this from the
other side but i can
remember
what in
[Applause]
oh shoot okay you get shotgun you get
shotgun yeah you better run [ __ ]
yeah run run you want
you who played this game and by two i
mean me and
a shotgun
where you going [ __ ] where you going
where are you going where are you where
are you going where you going
where you going [ __ ] get back here
you think i'm done with you
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh missed me by that
much punk
oh you kind of hurt
but i also kind of hurt you yeah that's
right
yeah that's right okay ah there you go
there you go there you go yeah you stay
down you stay down okay cool
well that's not nearly as pretty as
crystal dimitrescu but you know
not everything can be the wounds are
severe i won't last much longer i can
hear shuffling outside
it barely flinched when i shot it feels
like it's toying with me
that isn't a wolf still i won't lie down
like a dog if i can get to the old water
mill i can stop it
i can protect you it's so close damn i'm
so cold
my legs won't work i'm so sorry louisa
please
forgive me well too bad i killed it and
you didn't because i'm
better than you how's that feel how's
that feel to suck
man must suck to suck but looks like i'm
just
[ __ ] amazing incredible even studly
huge bald that's me to a t
all right hello hi i can open this now
yes hello
mother miranda okay
oh okay so these treasures are kind of
worth it you know what i mean they're
kind of a little bit worth it
okay so if that was
wait a minute how do you get through
here was it blocked from the other side
and i'm just dumb
ah oh it probably wanted me to go
get this thing and then
face me fight me
fight me come at me bro
come at me chad lord lord of the chat oh
you're not worth it
you're not worth it bang but i missed
well i'm pretty terrible so you're lucky
and now you're not lucky
who did oh hey uh-huh
okay you're dead great good stuff what's
this all about
okay why were you here there's chickens
back there
there's chickens that need killing
chickens
hello did someone order
some chicken
i hear you i don't know when i became
this bloodthirsty
probably the repeated bites from all the
werewolves but i'm gonna
kill chickens where are you
where are these chickens where the hell
are they
oh i see wheel
oh chickens
chickens hmm all right you live for now
i'll get you next time though your days
are quite numbered my friends okay so i
can get over here now
i probably need to go back up i
definitely need to go back up okay
so i'm gonna go back up and i'm gonna go
around and then i'm gonna see about that
door but i doubt that i can open it
i also don't know why this area was
locked so tightly behind
this locked door when i originally came
here in the first place but
that's his life hey i killed a beast you
want it naturally
i don't like that you actually answered
my question but uh there you go
you guy more than bullets
no you don't could do these though
that's pretty good i saw you eyeing that
one thanks
stop looking at my eyes
cool later nerd see you around douche
yeah you do [ __ ] yeah was this just
like
no there's no way this was not openable
it's just for some reason a weird
permanently locked door which makes
perfect sense if you don't think about
it so stop thinking about it
all right luther's key
i don't know who luthier is
peekaboo thank you
you yes no maybe so
i was promised great treasures i do not
see
incredible treasure oh
okay fine is there some kind of a clue
in here
yeah i got a crystal oh yellow quartz
well that's interesting okay is there
more stuff like that
that wasn't even like a shiny thing it
just was ah
it's gonna be a freaking oh
it's gonna be a freaking oh
was that the treasure that was not the
treasure
there's no way that's it god damn you
[ __ ] oh hello i'll never forget her
fifth birthday who who's you talking
about
her specifically fifth birthday
i'll never forget i'm luthier
i'm in oh ah her
fifth birthday okay is that it 2709
17 17.
okay all right well that was easy man
they do not make these difficult
oh wow if only i used that gun
which i don't well that's that treasures
and there's some treasure over shares
but i don't want to go over there
i'll go god damn it skip skip skip skip
skip skip
well unskip
oh i know what to do with that i know
what to do with that
definitely very valuable i bet
very valuable very valuable
oh door oh ooh okay unskip
oh i forgot about this right
okay good where am i
die die i just built one of you should i
break it
what do they even do
give me your feathers anymore
oh no oh no oh no
thanks thanks pal thank you was there
any other reason besides that to come
back here
it must have been right look from the
other side what do you mean from the
other side
there's something secret here there's
definitely something secret here
something secret is definitely here
something secret is totally here
but how and why and how
and also why and appears like a bunch of
nothing
all right uh elixie and please skip
again
uh-huh well that's weird what are those
guys
doing up there also there's a well in
the backyard there
oh oh hey bud nah but
man you guys take up too many bullets
i'm never going to be able to have
enough uh
boink boink wink boink
jesus what are you doing sorry i have to
do this
you're infected or something it's a
zombie pig it's cool guys
good god just hold oh my god
this is oh my god
i have a bit of a okay here we go and
then
quality me good good good good
oh my god
okay good thank you thank you thank you
oh god oh god where'd you come these
guys are so buggy
okay good hey and wheel all right
good job everybody we're really cleaning
up house here
there are pipe bombs in there guys did
you know that they were pipe bombs
oh bestie hey you all right in there
how's your uh papa
wow holy [ __ ]
uh okay so where's this trip
wow uh where's this treasure supposed to
be
oh
thanks louisa glad that fell perfectly
here i'm guessing i won't be able to
ever get back in there
hmm somehow i'm not sad about that
okay whatever bye later nerds all right
lexie and please skip
hi duke i'll be right with you one
second i've got some quality me oh no
ah i gotta start overriding ooh i hate
it oh hate it hi
dude feel free to peruse i will peruse
can i cook anything i don't know if
these are like
permanent upgrades they're probably not
right
i could do an herbed fish health
slightly increases
permanently what i will eat
yeah yes i can hardly wait
just excuse me a moment you can hardly
wait i'm eating it
apologies for the wait here's your share
my my share
my my share my share my share
my share oh [ __ ] i think such a dish
could be had in this
winterbound frontier well thank you for
it
uh i appreciate it really appreciate it
hey i had
fish hey what happened to all my fish
what the oh i used the fish but i had
six fish i
sold some fish you [ __ ] you stole my
fish
this [ __ ] stole my fish i don't think
that
this is combinable so i'll get that out
of there
uh ingrid's necklace that's why is that
so
little i would have thought that would
have been more okay wouldn't go it i
completed that
right get rid of that steel
official rare river get rid of that okay
keep the poultry
okay that's 39 000 that's a lot splendid
never do i know it's worth
apparently i don't what kind of question
you ask that before i right after i sell
it to you
appears to be alive
okay cool that's weird um explosive
rounds yes i see
anything else flashbangs yes um pipe
bombs
sure uh splooshy absolutely
please come again always my dude okay
where am i headed though
so it was down there was i went down
here but why
that's the question this got unlocked
but
why it couldn't have been just for this
gun there must be something
else down this way that is of
use now dead end here
it looks breakable though okay well
stand back everybody
all right well that worked out well but
why is it so
goopy why is everything so goopy i don't
like the goop
i'm a genius oh
i j i can jump i can jump
oh you picks are going down
oh you pigs oh you pigs oh bye bye piggy
[Music]
[Laughter]
this says nothing about me all fine
okay at least i got my path back
that seems a little bit noisy for what's
going on there
okay so i don't have that yet
i'm gonna need that ooh another ball
thing
if only i had a ball
hello oh my goodness what's you uh
what's your grind in there
oh hello reservoir elevator uh why is
everything gotta have elevators you know
why is everything elevator based
photo of a rare animal i already killed
it my dude i
already killed it my dude it is dead it
took a lot of killing but it is dead my
dude
it is dead hello
okay i guess i'll go down then
oh my hand i'm surprised i can still use
it
so soon after it got sliced off
remember the memories dimitriska dome
remember them fond memories we had
together great
memories incredible memories
the memories were great between you and
me
just such a short amount of time
together such great may
maurice
all right well this isn't creepy at all
it's not as creepy as the doll place but
you know it's still
not that creepy i just wish i knew why
everything was covered in boogers
because it's it is really everything is
absolutely booked up
all right i'm guessing this is still can
i just use one of these
did that oh no i okay i just had to
squeeze well that was a waste of a pipe
hey well hi hi there can i just take it
i know you're watching your favorite tv
show but i'm just gonna nab this thing
thank you
okay that's unnecessary
hi hey what's up i'm gonna throw a pipe
just taking this wait wait wait what are
you doing with
mother's special child she's not hers
oh you have something to say
what do you mean mother's special child
mother
wants her baby back don't screw with me
wait wait wait
please please if you take it then the
others
laugh at me but if i had you
better than them what do i care wait
just a little longer
[Music]
what do you
[ __ ] yeah i probably should have not
done that
i probably should freaked probably
shoulda you know
ran or something i'm real good at
running my legs real strong oh hey
what's up buddy
uh but why not though but uh
[Music]
how do i get out of here it seems like
you didn't plug the way in my dude my
dude it seems like i'm
unplugged uh my broseph
seems like i'm uh completely free to go
wherever the hell i want to go
my dude i see the arrow over there and
i'm gonna get it eventually but i need
to explore this place first
leave the boat key in the shack in the
mine han is dead so no more fishing for
a while i mean
we all know his death was no accident he
was eaten by a giant
fish boat and all that does not
boat well for me
uh nah the giant fish does sound like
giant fish is gonna have giant meat
so uh that's pretty cool i guess i gotta
boat it up
i did not have i didn't know i needed
didn't know this was necessary i need a
boot key okay
hans had the boat key inside the mine it
said so
somewhere in here i mean i could just
jump
there but whatever somewhere in here
there's a key
or a dude with a key or some kind of key
dude
come on i find it
oh well that's yellow ah
i knew it okay
jumpis
that worked out perfectly i love it when
a plan comes together
yeah more any more bogeys
why hello
did i miss something why did the music
go all ominous
okay all right
well i'm not particularly worried about
that
hi it's me hi how you doing yeah
oh oh you coming in quick hey hey not so
hot not so heavy
damn it there we go
okay yeah you guys gotta woo
me first i need to be wooed
hello oh
well all right let's do this hey what's
up bud
now don't come in the back way that's
the way i really
don't want you to come in oh you got the
armor
hey stop hey hey hey hey dick
dick gets a face full of this
sorry but oh you bang a
bubble oh [ __ ]
oh my guts
shoot shoot no no not like not i i
really should have gotten the rate of
fire
modification
i'm gonna kill you because i don't know
thank you
no thank you
you know what take some eat oh
there's no way you're still yeah i
didn't think so i didn't think so
all right well you know what
i just don't like you
congratulations you deserve that
dick you guys done
done being a bunch of [ __ ] there any
fish down here i bet there are
i bet there's totally fish in here no
that's a barrel piece
fish fishes fishus
damn it they hit all the fish no fish
ems
but there's more stuff in here where's
more stuff
i'm not gonna miss out on the stuff well
i can't find anything so
must be either well hidden or i'm stupid
which is probably the more likely
outcome
all right going backwards then
oh unless it's right here
ah still not it whatever it's fine
not a big deal not my main concern my
main concern is getting out of here and
my daughter i gotta deal with that
she's in a few pieces but i think i'll
be able to
get her back up labyrinth puzzle
okay labyrinth i don't know what that is
about
oh it's the thing upstairs that's right
it's the uh the the ball
thing but i got the boat key now so i
can do that wherever that's gonna take
me
and who knows at this point i think it's
really
blushing hey
hey i don't have any of those
hey a bang boom
bam love it
all right i thought i heard someone
behind me
boat time i'm gonna get eaten by
apparently a giant fish but there's
gonna be giant fish meat
which would be pretty dope
uh so where am i going with this do i
actually control it
no but how am i gonna this doesn't make
any sense how am i gonna get back there
interesting okay well this is weird i
guess i'll go in the big tunnel
oh
what was that okay when you said
big fish for some reason
my brain didn't consider that big so
uh that's great
um really cool and all
so i'm gonna get out of the water now
i'm gonna get
out the water and i'm never gonna go
back in the water
you know uh just how it's gonna be where
does this go
hello freedom freedom
freedom oh pretty
freedom hello oh god oh my god you
scared the ever loving
potatoes out of me jesus give me your
glorious fish meat
all right well that was fun um beautiful
home you had
uh but you'll be having an even more
beautiful home inside my belly
so you can think about it that way and
you can you'd be pretty happy with it
you know
you know what i'm saying you know what
i'm saying i think you know what i'm
saying hello
hello hello oh what the hell
research post or something oh that's not
good what are you doing here
oh yeah hello hi
oh hi no let's not fight come on we're
on the same team
stay the [ __ ] down ethan
hi gotta say i'm surprised you made it
this far uh hi
it'd be a shame if something happened to
you now sir chris
why not you killed mia now do me and
finish the job
hey cat i'm getting some serious motion
readings out here
we should move on
what kind of readings what's moving
unknown but my guess
is we've been here too long and miranda
knows it hey hey
did you say miranda how are you involved
leave it alone ethan you are out of your
depth
what about the sample analysis it's
definitely related to the mold
you stay out of our business
oh mama
uh
okay well that was cool
um
uh okay
oh hi hey what's up stay back
you're done i don't have time for this
[Music]
miranda sent you to slow me down
what are you talking about
[Music]
okay
okay all right oh that was you
you was the big fish oh okay all right
okay okay okay okay
i get you i get you all right great
hey thank you well
uh big preach on all that you've done to
help
me and uh hope you have a lovely
adventure in whatever hell hole you're
gonna find yourself in
do i still have uh crystal dimitrescu
yes i do
thank you everybody so much for watching
that will do it for today's episode
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below now that i've properly
escaped from that monster forever and i
don't have to deal with it anymore
that was a close one everybody but we
made it out alive really appreciate you
sticking it out with me
we're in this together but we're out of
the woods now safe
flying from here on out thank you and as
always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you